alex and i
work together at a company called
platter we build branchable postgres
but this talk is about something
slightly more general it's about branch
stack something we're calling branch
stack because it makes it easier to give
it a name and talk about it but the idea
is we branch state to develop
distributed systems if you want to
follow up with us afterwards about this
you can also besides the slack find us
on github and twitter
alex is only on github because he's
working hard all the time i'm on twitter
mostly to tell the bad jokes that
otherwise will get me banned at the
workplace so
all right let's go branch stack
branching state to develop distributed
systems so first i'd like to start with
story time where i started as a
developer
so this conference strange loop for me
2012
was the first conference i had ever gone
to
furthermore i was in the middle of a
career change so i felt very much like i
did not fit in here like i did not
belong
i'm a band director a musician by
training i made a big switch and i just
happened to come to this conference
because a friend said it was great i got
here and i was just i felt like i was in
over my head so much cool stuff so much
amazing material everybody seemed to
know everybody and that was a really
uncomfortable feeling for me so if
you're in that place right now
i just like to encourage you to reach
out to people because i sat down at a
random table at a dinner and that's how
i got my first job so i literally owe my
career and the trajectory it's taken to
this conference
if i can help any of you in that same
respect i would love to so please please
reach out
okay so another story time even further
back hyper card anybody here know hyper
card
oh good this is my room awesome so so
hyper card is how i learned to code
similar to being a musician and then
only later becoming a programmer i used
what they would today call a low code
tool to learn to code
and and it was a glorious one what it
gave me is in a word in two words i
guess unrealistic expectations
right and that's a good thing that's a
wonderful thing
and what i want to show you really
quickly just in case you haven't seen it
is how hyper card works
so this looks like a video it's not
but somewhere
yeah other way there we go okay so
here's hypercard this is running on
system 7.5.3 by the way and if you
google
7.5.3 hypercard you can run this thanks
to archive.org literally in your browser
yea virtualization
so i'm going to double click and this is
key
on my application on my stack and now
i'm in my home stack
i'm going to get that play
display out of the way hopefully
okay so anyways i go to card three
and i have a button
i'm a strange loop i am a strangle oop
we're doing anagrams of strange loop
here obviously so that's good there's my
application it's already running i
double clicked i'm using it
i quit hyper card
i use a system level facility
to do something amazing still to me i
duplicate it right computers yeah they
got a lot of storage
we don't have to do things to the
existing application so i make a copy of
my home copy of my home stack
i open it up as well
everything's there it's the same as i
expected but it's time to make some
really important changes so i'm going to
open up the button editor i forget the
actual name of this it's been a long
time i wrote this on the vm i was proud
i could still write some hyper talk
i'm going to add a new option so strange
loop can be arranged as strangle oop
which is a classic interpretation
but there's another anagram which is
protean slog which is the way it feels
to develop systems in the web i would
say today distributed systems
so i save that
i click on it i'm a strange loop no
maybe i'm a strangle op no i'm protein
slug yes
good
so
i've made my change i've branched my
project
i'm going to ship it now
if i were to ship this in 1985 or 1987
when hypercard was first created
obviously i'd be copying to a floppy
shipping it in boxes that's the hard
part this is taken care of for us that's
a good thing we have distribution built
in to our computer systems that's why
they're distributed systems it's there
already
but for now i'm just going to create a
tada button i'm going to click it
ship it
or shipped
i now know how my system works i know
it's going to work exactly the same for
my users modulo a few concerns we won't
talk about here i can copy protect this
which is an evil thing but i can make
this a read-only deck i can put it on a
floppy and i can send it to all my
friends i can sell it
ten dollars a piece that's great awesome
so that's hypercard that's how i learned
to program
here we go okay so what can i do just to
recap i can start the thing right away
just just think about that for a while
if you go join a new company right now
and there's an application you want to
work on can you start the thing right
away
i can make it make a copy and i can
start changing it right away there's a
crucial
distinction between the systems of
that are simple on a single computer and
distributed systems
i can ship it and i can ship it with
confidence i know what the experience is
going to be like
okay so now let's talk about the systems
most of us if not all of us work on and
they're complexity they're in the cloud
they're distributed systems they have
communication pro protocols they have
interleaved state between each of these
nodes
on this workflow this is a real product
by the way this is our failed first
product at platter which was like one
click applications
whole web applications so that's what it
looked like
so i have some questions can i start it
right away
can you start the application that you
want to work on right away at work
can you make or
make your own copy and start to change
it without worrying that you're going to
accidentally
you know destroy prod that you're going
to destroy another developer's workflow
is it a copy in the first place
if you're running it locally in a bunch
of docker containers with different
network conditions different
dependencies injected in different ways
do you know that you're working on a
copy of your application
can you ship it with confidence based on
that knowledge
the answer for me
in every company that i've worked at
even the ones that had the best
developer tooling is no there are too
many variables
thinking functionally we have not
parameterized our system over all the
right things
that we can just plug new ones in
is this a fair comparison though
i will also say no there so what
happened what happened between 1987 and
now
multiplayer web and mobile right so
multiplayer applications distributed
clients people doing stuff to your app
at the same time distributed systems and
state these things did exist of course
before 1987 but this is this is about me
this is my experience
and it's about how my expectations
really are unreasonable and how that's a
good thing a brief digression this is
the strange loop comp website 2010
you can find this also on archive.org
this is
what the conf was about one year after
its inception this is the meta tag from
today it this actually doesn't display
on the site anymore but what do we see
concurrent and distributed systems
symantec web
that that one's a throwback
mobile apps right so web apps front end
web we see distributed systems we see
databases
it is obviously strange loop's fault
that we can no longer branch and work on
our systems right
but
am i being unreasonable i am right
um
this is kind of i want to unpack the
sentence yes i'm being unreasonable and
that's a good thing
so there's a lot of inherent complexity
in the systems we build and deploy
and it's fun it's really fun to build
them and it's really fun to understand
that complexity to rock it if you're not
familiar with the term grocking means
like a excited understanding right the
kind of understanding that you feel
sympathy with the system you feel as if
it's moving your brain in a pleasant way
and we love this about our systems
but it doesn't mean just because we love
to build systems like this and we love
to understand them that we should accept
difficulty in working with them this is
the work of developer tools
right developer tools aren't tools that
developers use
developer tools are turning is is
turning computers against themselves so
that we have more leverage
so that we have more abstraction so that
we have a clearer view of what the
system should do at a higher level
so
you cannot put the toothpaste back in
the tube these systems are very very
complex
the question that we ask is can we find
ways to make working with them radically
easier not incrementally easier not i
can put this in a docker container and i
all i need is 16 gigs of ram and gigabit
fiber and then i can kind of run it can
we do something better than that is our
is our question for this talk
so how do we make working on and
deploying modern distributed software
more like developing and deploying in
hypercard
is the is the question of this talk
attempt one
put it all on my machine
who has ever joined a company where
there was a readme a really long readme
that started with like operating system
and shared libs
that moved on to uh downloading the
various frameworks involved in the
application setting up localhost or etsy
hosts your file for local networking
uh connecting all the pieces then
running your application
anybody ever joined a company like that
how long did it take just yell it out
a week
three days
a few a few days i've heard weeks i've
heard a month i've heard more than
months i once worked at a company which
shall remain unnamed where the general
feeling was that it would take you six
months before you are up and running and
productive
i want you to think about the um average
tenure of a software engineer at a
company these days that's like 30 waste
right 30 frustration even more
importantly for us individually
so it's waste for the business it's
waste for us as developers it's a lack
of learning about the system and the
company and the business and most
importantly the people we build the app
for in the first place it's very
frustrating so can i start it right away
no no no
all right attempt two containerize it
all on my machine docker is great right
no more shared libs no more operating
system setup except for docker machine
and giving it eight gigs at least of ram
and four cores
so can i start it right away
yes 16 gigs of ram gigabit fiber if you
close chrome if you close slack and if
you are still pretty early as a company
right there's a lot
there's a lot to running one of these
systems on your machine
can i make or change my own copy
think about this
think about the systems you worked on
that are dockerized that have all of
this awesome maybe stalker compose maybe
it's composed with a k
so that it automatically translates to
kubernetes we set this up last time it
was painful
can you make or change
your own copy of the system
no
right so what's different
network conditions are absolutely
different right but there's there's
there's more that's different that's
deeper and subtler about the system what
about the state itself
on these readmes is there ever a place
where you say
dump a copy of the prod database
restore it make sure you delete all of
the records with this id or this
sensitive information or run this script
to destroy
uh the depersonalize the emails social
security numbers hopefully not god
hopefully not but you get the idea right
running a copy even if you take care of
the operating system concern of
virtualization and of multi-tenancy
which is what containers do for us
there's still a whole lot to making a
running copy of your system
okay so attempt three can we do this
can we just pull a menu down and this
this is actually the shortcut i did it
the long way in the video i realized but
inside hypercard itself there is save a
copy make a copy of the whole thing
but in the cloud
can we do that
can i start it right away
just just pretend we've done that okay
can i start right away it's already
running and it's always been running i
can play with the application
can i make or change my own copy this is
kind of dilemma here and this is what
alex is going to show you how to
actually do in a demo
i tried to make him do live code spaces
demo but i think we're going to defer to
video because wi-fi
so and can i ship it with confidence
it really did the thing's already
shipped in fact it's already on the
exact same systems and subsystems that
you run your production cluster on maybe
it's a different name space maybe it's a
different endpoint but you are already
shipped
now there's a little question about
merge so we build a branching database
do you actually want to merge your
database probably not just your
migrations so you run your migrations
over prod data but because stuff is
branchable we can branch our prod
database
pre-flight the migrations on it make
sure that works before we even ship prod
right branchable state pervasive
branchable systems are a superpower
why can't i copy change and deploy a
running distributed system one and this
is the hardest one i think legacy wet
wear works on my machine while we like
to joke about it it's still our favorite
thing to do
i love to fire up my
16 gig of ram does yours have 16 too
okay yeah well 16 or 8 gigs of ram
machine i love to start a terminal
uh you know run a make file or dot slash
start dot sh whatever the way i start my
application is i love that feeling i
even love doing it on an airplane or a
train
totally away from the internet and
working on it that's that's an addictive
thing right
but as i said we can't oh sorry we can't
really
put the toothpaste back in the tube the
system that we are working on runs in a
single global environment
with all of the things that can go wrong
in that global environment and all the
things that are unique about it
we cannot work
only on our own machine
cloud costs
another question right how much is this
going to cost if i just make copies of
my system if profligate every time i
want to develop a feature i make a full
copy of of the system this is an
engineering question
we talked about kubernetes we talked
about containers and virtualization
right what can we do in terms of
multi-tenancy of stateful systems to
make the costs non-linear with how many
copies you're making there's actually a
lot that's what we've done in platter
for postgres and it's what we want to
suggest you can do with every staple
system even third-party systems that
have state a payment service like stripe
for instance we learned a lot about the
stripe api the other day we have a
feature request for stripe and it's api
coming in this freeze though
and three simple ain't easy
yet
right
so so there's a lot going on here i want
to drill into this point
uh first
if you have not seen richie's video 2012
strange loop i think recently remastered
by alex if he's out there thank you for
that
search for rich hickey simple easy video
put it in a tab and watch this video
later because it certainly changed my
career and the way i thought about the
systems i work on
in a way a lot of what comes out in this
talk is from that talk
now have i based it probably so
apologies rich but i hope that the
pragmatism uh pays off some
okay so in that talk rich hickey says
that state is a complexion of values
with time just to unpack that word
complex versus simple things folded
together that you want to be separate
that's what complexion means
so state is a complexion of values one
three the row of the database with time
i can change the state
but the reference is the same
that's what makes something stateful i
haven't separated the value of something
from the time i'm looking it up
distributed products
are composed of stateful subsystems so
we're not at the single program level
here anymore we're at the architecture
level i've got a postgres database that
has a url that innocently looks like
it's still the same postgres database
but what has happened meanwhile
all kinds of things
right changes to the data to the
metadata to the conf file it's restarted
i don't know where it came from i don't
know how to reproduce it
most importantly
anybody here ever had an application go
down for more than a day because the
database got trashed
as as expected strangely pretty good
crowd four hands for those of you uh
sitting at at home not bad but painful
when it happens
so distributed systems and products are
a graph indeed of stateful subsystems
and we might represent that graph top
down like we're first tempted to i have
an app there's a little code example
here it has a front end that front end
needs an auth service and i want the
auth service to branch from dev i want
the same users as i have in my dev
environment
i have a payment system same thing dev
i have dns
right allowing me to touch this system i
have a back end then this is very
simplified it has a database i want a
branch from dev
i have a payment service note this is a
shared dependency
uh and then i have a platform i want to
deploy it on and that thing has logging
in dev and then i ran out of space on
the slide but you know how this works
right it's dependency after dependency
after dependency this is the top down or
the imperative view we have built this
many times at companies we worked at to
spin things up and it always breaks
every time because it's not run all the
time
so let's do something let's invert it
into dependencies instead of the top
down command and control start up the
system
like so
now we have a back end and we have a
front end we know we want to spin them
up because
implicitly to the right of this is app
the back end is dependent on platform db
and payments we want to branch those
things from the dev line front end same
thing right this should look familiar
because this is make files this is
github actions this is any workflow
runner that models dependencies runs
everything it can
concurrently if you dash j your makefile
i guess
your your make invocation but this this
is something we know how to do right the
only question now is how do we branch
those base stateful services before they
hit the functional components of our
system that the last 10 years of strange
loop have taught us to extract from our
state
this is our api that
inverts
the concerns here and asks for its
database when it starts up and fails to
start up if it doesn't have that
database connection string but how do we
branch the database so that we know
we're not destroying alex's presentation
at strange loop while i'm at a customer
site
right
so we can run it and make we can run it
in ci we can run it on any dependency
based workflow runner
just to remind you
we're pretty deep now what was the
question why can't i copy change and
deploy a running distributed system
i think we can it's just a lot of work
and we never have time to do it at the
companies we're at right all of us see
this every time we started a new company
we maybe improve the read me we make one
piece of it more failure tolerant but do
we ever build the tool
that lets us
not only start this system up
but create a new system with its
dependencies such that we can branch
that system instantly do we ever create
the templating system that branches all
of the state underneath so that dev on
any part of our company's infrastructure
or application stack is as simple as
cloning and starting
i
i haven't had the time i've asked for it
that's why we started a startup because
we want to do it
so it takes elbow grease but it also
takes wrapping paper
right
you can do this in your system right now
all of the elements are there
but
if you try to do it one off or two off
or for three systems
you're gonna you're gonna repeat
yourself in some places you're gonna
find some patterns that were unhealthy
right so what we really need to do is
pull out this kind of workflow into um
i'm gonna say methodology i know that's
a loaded word right but what i mean
there is a set of tools and methods that
allow us this kind of workflow
we need to do the work of developer
tools
turn the machine against itself so we
have more leverage
okay so
i've done a lot of talky talk i hope
it's helped to motivate what we do but
uh as as befits his superior technical
skill always alex is actually going to
demo this thing for you and he's going
to talk about how to branch a single
stateful service
how we might look at services that can
branch that have a lot of primitives
that help
and services that
look like any sas service you're using
right now that has no notion of
branching
so go ahead all right thanks patrick can
anybody hear me all right
all right
so
[Applause]
so we're calling this concept branch
stack and it's a couple of different
things like patrick already mentioned
we are envisioning branching services
wrapping existing services third-party
apis and
more base resources like postgres
databases in a branching first layer
we're envisioning development practices
like patrick mentioned we have a lot of
elbow grease we can already branch
systems individually if we take the time
to do so we mostly need a cultural shift
and we need some know-how about how we
can actually do this and of course we
need some more developer tools to make
it easier to do this because we all are
not lazy but let's say efficient
so how do i as a developer start
branching
let's talk about a couple of different
cases here um we work with a lot of
different systems
in a lot of cases we're working with
third-party systems that have no concept
of branching
this is a
a lot of times driven by apis driven by
requests and so what can we do as simply
a consumer of these apis to
differentiate between different
verticals different
buckets of state
in many cases what we're left with is
arbitrary metadata
if you are able to say push customer
data or push
any sort of
entity to one of these apis and you're
allowed to add your own keys and values
this can be a useful way of branching
in this case the logical branching
happens within application code and it
happens at the point of consumption
you can imagine for example a webhook
endpoint that receives a bunch of events
some of those events should happen for
development branches some of them should
happen for a particular feature and in
these situations perhaps the only way we
have of differentiating between them
would be to query this metadata in every
application handler across every branch
anybody's ops bells like ringing right
now that's dangerous right
scary
it is scary uh one of the things that's
scary is that if you're interacting with
one of these third-party services that
doesn't have any special cases uh it
makes it it means that as a consumer you
don't get to enforce any special cases
uh we'll talk in
more depth uh
about the payment processing special
case as an example in fact it's it's
impossible to treat these pieces of
metadata differently at the point where
you send them over to a third party
service
uh metadata is also hard like patrick
alluded to if your ops bells were
ringing when you talked about
ingesting events from all of the
developer branches that may or may not
be working at a particular time and then
special casing them within every
instance of this
application that is both a difficult
thing to do reliably because metadata is
itself not a reliable index um and it's
difficult to do performantly for large
enough data sets consuming systems must
filter all of these things and that's
that's not particularly easy
but it does work and we'll have an
example in our demo application of uh
doing just that
the second case which i think is more
common are buckets uh stripe is a good
example of doing this where you are able
to request data with an api key that's
live
and get back some sort of data and then
you have an entirely separate bucket for
test data it's the same endpoint with
different authorization
api keys effectively
this in our mind is
good in a lot of ways
in this case test data can behave
differently the special cases are
handled
production is itself protected however
if we're thinking about this as a
branching system you're restricted
effectively to two branches you have
production and then you have your very
precious test data
so what do you do in this case well
we're back to using metadata
and this is again effective and we will
see how we're able to leverage metadata
as a filtering tool in a branching
workflow in just a little bit but for
all the reasons that we talked about in
the previous slide this is still not as
optimal as being able to arbitrarily
copy
pieces of that test data at a particular
point in time
another popular approach
is what we'll call local emulation this
is of course
popular in front end development
specifically
we love our fast hot reloading
development loops in this case on
localhost
and getting our localhost to communicate
to
various systems that are deployed out in
the cloud
often means some sort of tunnel
ngrok is a great example netlify with
their live flag on netlify dev does
something very similar is that tunnel
live it's that just so much tunnel
tunnel life and
this of course does some great things
for us it gives us unique and shareable
branches we can be confident that what
i'm working on at least for these kinds
of applications is unique it's shareable
if you've got it tunneled onto a public
api or a public endpoint
but
fundamentally when we're working with a
large distributed system
exact emulation is impossible
excuse me
even with a system like netlify yes you
can use some
versions of their
internal systems but what about
identity what about using their cdn what
about their routing rules if we're using
our own tunnel to tunnel these things
through to a separate endpoint that's an
entirely separate set of
complex
intercedents where we ought to just be
using the production system
i think there's a cool approach with
cloudflare workers that they're working
on
where your workloads are actually run
on the cloudflare edge network even when
you're using wranglerdev and we'll see
that in in action too
this means for example that you can use
the production system
the
difference is that you are being
all those workloads are being tunneled
back again to your local system
there's an open github issue so that
workers can have public urls just like
the public edge network that they're
using
so go give that a thumbs up if you want
to see public endpoints for workers
worker workloads even for dev
environments
so what's the alternative to these
options
the alternative to these options is
as a service
building in branching
and what we mean by this
using
the same sort of authorization model
that we saw with the buckets
but making branches a named first class
citizen so if i wanted to
query my api for foos
i would need to query a specific branch
of foos
and i can keep these as separate
arbitrarily different
requests
if i wanted to create a new branch
my expectation would be that i can
create a new branch using another branch
as the parent so to speak and then i can
name that new branch
anything i want so you'll see here i've
modeled this out as a post to a branch's
endpoint at which point i can get the
exact same data as i had in the parent
branch by querying
the
feature branch
in this case
arbitrarily copying and
keeping these state totally separate and
accessible regardless of environment so
to speak
now you might be thinking
like patrick already mentioned well
if i want to be able to build one of
these apis myself
uh doesn't that mean
branching an entire say kubernetes
cluster our systems are large they are
expensive at many in many cases how do i
actually go about wrapping one of my own
services in this branching api
and i think the answer is that we choose
the right abstraction and then lean hard
into multi-tenancy
so if you have a software as a service
company
it makes sense to represent a subset of
data as a view or as an
index a column in a database it's simple
enough to keep all of that data in the
same place but provide a way for your
users to filter against that particular
set of data arbitrarily
if you are working with data or
databases a lot of times they come with
a clustering mechanism themselves
postgres is an example in which case we
can branch entire databases within the
same cluster and get the exact same
branching mechanics
without having to branch the entire
postgres cluster every single time which
would be cost and time
prohibited for things like lambda
functions or workers
there are
there's of course isolation built in at
the invocation level for each of these
functions but you can imagine that
revisions or individual edits to these
functions as well as a networking layer
a collection of endpoints would work
again as a different branch
kubernetes depending on the level of
isolation you need you could use pod
labels and then have your ingress
controller route to a particular pod
label in response to a
different request
you could use namespaces
again if you're running application code
with no expectation of using kubernetes
internal mpi or apis
or you can virtualize clusters there's
some good work going on in the
kubernetes world of using v clusters to
provide a much harder form of
multi-tenancy inside a single cluster
without having to go through and wait
for another hosted kubernetes cluster to
come up and we think these are all
viable strategies for implementing
branching in our own services
uh and with in our own and in our own
companies
uh so
of course those address the the cloud
costs ideas uh but what about ease of
use what about speed what does this
actually look like in a branching
service
uh well somewhat selfishly we'll show
you what it looks like in in platter
postgres uh so we've been working on
doing this specifically for postgres
databases do you want to bump the font a
little bit can we bump the font a little
bit oh man that's a good question
uh maybe not
we probably can with the right
you know what no no worries about the
fonts
oh you know what i did i didn't turn and
plug in my keyboard
[Laughter]
yes
that would have been the most awkward 10
minutes of our lives
okay
yes gotta have my keyboard alright so
now
so we should be able to
come on buddy
it's all right there's a built-in one
too if you need to yeah but it's
terrible it's a macbook keyboard
[Music]
2016 that is
vintage
we're gonna give this one more try and
if this doesn't work then i'll have to
have to use the old butterfly switches
yes all right hello world
oh man those just sound better too
all right so let's talk about platter
uh we've created a cli tool that wraps
the same sort of api um
font size yeah give it a try we're gonna
see if i can do it see if i got the
right keyboard shortcut actually
can i just zoom it
no
i'm not sure sorry about that guys no
worries
oh
nope i don't know the right keyboard
shortcut okay sorry about that
so what we're going to do is i would
like to list
all of the branches of a postgres
database that i might have active for
we call them instances
of a widget service demo uh this platter
cli i've already um
authorized and authenticated and of
course
forgot the list command there we go so
hopefully you guys can see that um we
have two branches here we have main
which is our protected production branch
and we have development which is
specifically for
development work it's a smaller subset
of data it is quicker to clone it's
quicker to branch
and in this case
we want to be able to
use a branching
command in the middle of our developer
life cycle and we'll talk about how we
can trigger this branching command that
i'm about to show you on git checkout in
a little bit
so platter postgres
branch create
we are going to create a new speech
branch called strange loop or strangle
oop
from an instance
with a parent of develop
meant
to do and there we have a new database
based off of our development um database
and we can treat this as a totally
separate branch for our
for our active system
that means of course that we can
directly access it lighter postcards
branch url
string
loop
i said to that a little bit too early
but it did work
so we have of course a bunch of things
in our database if we wanted to we could
create a new table
test with an id serial
processor oh we're going to run out big
serial
it's on a branch though doesn't matter
we can insert into tests
uh default values so we can actually
insert some stuff
and we can double check that we've
actually created a test database we've
actually created the sequence and of
course we have some things
in our
from test
we actually have some things in our test
table uh what's most important about
this though is that we were able to do
all of that important iterative work
without touching development
you'll see that there is no test in
development which is important
when it came time to uh when our feature
work was done and it came time to
reconcile these two branches of course
we wouldn't want to take the state from
our new feature branch and try and
inject that or merge into our
development branch but we do have great
mechanisms for merging the schema in
terms of migrations so real world talk
while alex moves to the to the next demo
now and deletes that branch
this means that most client sites we end
up with long-running limited data on
development
that takes many branches at the same
time
we end up with merges back into a main
branch which takes schema only and this
is really where the customization of
each service to your application depends
is why we think of this as a life cycle
now unless as a top down problem
so you would merge in the schema changes
the migrations
so
what does it look like in an actual
application um i've we've come up with a
little widget service demo that we'll
show you in video form actually updating
and what this workflow would look like
but uh let's take a look at
two minutes
two minutes awesome it's gonna be great
so
we've got a static site uh that we are
going to use um code spaces to tunnel
through just like we i talked about for
local emulation again we'd love to see a
system that allowed development against
public uris with a little bit more
ease of use we're going to use
cloudflare workers and the wrangler dev
function that actually invokes those
workers against the edge network we're
going to
with each branch configure a new webhook
endpoint against a stripe payment
service and we are going to persist all
of that to a platter postgres database
we're using internal apis for all of the
or for cloudflare workers that make it
impossible for us to actually emulate
this locally
the server sent events that we have
going on
so let's see what that would look like
in action i recorded this in video form
because i'm a coward and because i
wanted to make sure that um
that
this works without wi-fi so what we have
here is a code space and i know that uh
text is really small but i will describe
what's going on here we have here a code
space that is
configured with all the proper
environment variables and we have live
against a preview url provided by code
spaces our little widget store
this is of course on the development
branch
we are interacting with that one
extremely purple widget
and what i'm uh what i would like to do
is on git checkout
i would like to automatically go through
the provisioning of a new database
branch the provisioning of a new stripe
web hook the
sinking of data between the two and the
rebuilding of our workers and api to
handle these new verticals
all that was done basically through uh
scripting we're passing inputs in
on one end and out on the other in about
as simple a way as we could possibly do
this to show that this is more of a
development practice rather than a set
of tools that are existing right now
that's bash and jq everybody that's bash
chrome jq
in this case i'm making the api public
again on our new branch
showing that we can log in with an
entirely separate set of sessions
that don't carry over between the two
purchase a widget with
uh
the actual stripe
checkout
workflow and as this workflow goes on it
will be sending events to a
webhook endpoint that is public
but still being actively developed on
that is unique to this particular branch
and all of the events that are coming
down that pipeline are
tagged with metadata so that we can as
consumers
distinguish between each of those events
as they come in
which means we then persist them to the
database now we have two widgets this
one a more tasteful gray
and as we
as we check our original development
branch back out
we can see that again the reconciliation
process goes through it doesn't take
very long should be on the order of
seconds as opposed to on the order of
minutes which means that we can
integrate this directly into the same
life cycle that we use with git
and then
[Music]
we'll see in a second that the data from
the original development
hasn't been touched
once my session refreshes you can now
create new users you can delete them uh
with abandon which is you know off third
party systems this is a big sticking
point for developability
yeah so uh what do we learn here we're
almost out of time yeah let's rush
through maybe exactly at a time so i'm
gonna take my points from now on it
cannot work on your machine anymore it's
sad but it's true the thing is running
in the in in the global distributed
computer that is the cloud and that's
where we are but what can we do about
that
we can make sure that these systems are
branchable and that that branching can
be as fast and easy as git checkout and
this is where the elbow grease comes in
right there's a lot of work to be done
induction though we didn't talk about it
you can now deploy multi-tenant systems
the same way right it's just public
endpoints instead of private dev
endpoints
you can now deploy entire new empty
copies of prod to really test prod if
you need to on a new endpoint without
affecting prod
this this is a primitive in developer
workflows but it's also a primitive in
your business you can now create an
entire new instance of the app to test
the feature with a business user as part
of checking out a branch you can send
them the link after five seconds make
the change they see what's going on they
delete the user and we're not worried
anymore that our system is is fragile
that it's going to break
so that's that's what we've been working
on in branch stack uh we're out of time
for questions unfortunately in the
session we want to be considerate to
whoever's speaking next so we're going
to hop off stage but we'll hang out over
here if you'd like to ask any particular
questions thank you so much for your
time thank you
[Music]
you